I know who her new BFF is and I can't
tell you I can't but I can I promise you
it's it's brilliant and unexpected and
just so good okay frenemy oh I think oh
I don't know about any frenemies I mean
she's on a clear mission as everybody is
to deal with someone with a glove and I
think that that's you know the most
important issue so I think people are
grouping together to take care of this
task
you
hey everybody its charlie
karen gillan was talking all about her
secret captain marvel new best friend
and Avengers 4 and the plot of Avengers
4 and how her mission hasn't changed
it's all about Thanos so now we have a
pretty good idea for how Captain Marvel
fits into the story and why she's so
critical to getting rid of Thanos at the
end of the movie so if you're brand new
to the channel there's a new round of
that infinity war blu-ray giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video I'll name a new winner at the end
of this so what she's saying exactly is
is that you know I have a new secret
best friend I totally can't tell you
about it's totally unexpected because
nobody had seen Captain Marvel at that
point this interview question was about
Avengers 4 but while they were doing
infinity war press before the movie had
come out so nobody had seen that Captain
Marvel post-credit scene so we didn't
know how the movie was gonna invoke her
so what she's saying is is Captain
Marvel is a really big part of her
storyline in her story line is
relatively simple just in terms of the
number of different things that she's
trying to do because remember what the
Russo said about the characters and
infinity war and the characters and
Avengers 4 they said that all the
characters that got a lot of screen time
during infinity war would not be
featured a lot during Avengers 4 except
for the original Avengers because
Avengers 4 is all about them coming
together and becoming true Avengers with
the help of Captain Marvel
so if nebula had all these moments
during infinity war it means that she
probably doesn't have a ton of scenes
during Avengers 4 just things that
revolve around defeating Thanos planning
to defeat him and then actually fighting
him and getting rid of him at the end of
the movie he should have killed me would
have been a waste of parts
they're gonna be a lot of really big
crazy twists and payoffs but you could
say that she's around for some of the
most important big payoffs like killing
Thanos rescuing Gamora from the
soulstone things that connect Thanos's
arc with gamora's arc and nebulas arc
because they're kind of like this really
twisted family
so obviously Gamora loves her sister but
she also really wants to kill thanos
even if they're not gonna do it exactly
like it happened in the comics during
the comic book there's a scene where he
tortures nebula to try and impress death
that's very similar to the scene where
he was torturing nebula on his ship when
he was trying to find the soul stones
location
don't do this some time ago your
sister's snuck aboard this ship to kill
me very nearly succeeded the comic book
just lays it on a little bit thicker
that Thanos is the most abusive dad in
the history of abusive dad's so nebula
wanting revenge for that says finally
enough is enough
so once the Avengers get the gauntlet
off of Thanos
she's able to steal it tries to use it
to get rid of Thanos now they're able to
stop her before she wreaks too much
havoc but she kind of goes mad with
power for a brief period because she's
been abused for so long so the movie is
already changing a whole bunch of things
about that comic book storyline so I
don't think we're gonna actually see
that go down exactly the same way but it
just gives you an idea for what nebulas
arc is get rid of Thanos kill him at any
cost like that guardians of the galaxy
scene that's all she cares about so if
she's saying that Captain Marvel is her
new best friend that means the Captain
Marvel is instrumental in defeating
Thanos and getting good more out of the
soul stone it's also part of the reason
why Captain Marvel needs to be so
powerful like they've been hyping her up
like she's gonna be a super big badass
but there's actually a practical reason
for why she's the right character based
on her power set and the way her
abilities work because she can counter
Thanos while he's wearing the gauntlet
and the other Avengers don't have a lot
of abilities that can do that Thor with
storm breakers the closest example to
that and if there was any confusion
about what Thanos is gonna be able to do
during Avengers 4 because of that last
scene where his arm is all screwed up
and the gauntlets all melted the
explanation that the Russos gave based
on that is that there's a cost to using
all six Infinity stones together the way
he did he was one of the only people in
the universe that was powerful enough
naturally to pay that price so that's
why his arm is gonna be messed up for
the rest of his life but the stones are
still good that's why he's able to use
them to port all the way across the
universe to his farm at the end of the
movie
you do what you do so if it wasn't clear
all the stones are still good otherwise
he wouldn't have been able to do that
like he would have just still been left
standing there with that blank look on
Thor's face what did you do a better
example would be if someone like Black
Widow tried to wield the gauntlet
because she's just a normal human
assassin she would probably be killed in
the act by all the energy coursing
through her and be trapped by the soul
stone this sort of gets back to that Red
Skull explainer scene where he talks
about the cost there's a certain wisdom
that comes with it like in order to
wield the gauntlet you have to wield the
soul stone in order to do that you have
to be able to sacrifice the thing that
you love so that's why he was trapped by
the soul stone when he tried to wield it
because he didn't have anybody else or
any other things that he loved besides
himself so if you don't fulfill that
requirement and you're just not
naturally powerful enough to sustain all
that energy coursing through you you'll
end up dying when you try to wield the
gauntlet Thanos has the blood of the
Eternals flowing through his veins so
even without the gauntlet he's one of
the most naturally powerful people in
the universe which is why she needs to
be so powerful at the beginning of
Avengers 4 so like Thor was Stormbreaker
is a good power scaling benchmark
Stormbreaker is able to cut the
collected beams of all six stones and
Pierce Thanos his skin
Captain Marvel has to be able to counter
a full blast from the Infinity Gauntlet
and there are really two reasons why she
can do that one because of her natural
cosmic ability to absorb energy any kind
of energy to a point it's not infinite
like she couldn't just sit there soaking
the full blast of the Infinity Gauntlet
for forever eventually she'd be
vaporized even though the gauntlet is a
little messed up the gems are still good
Thanos will still be able to use the
gauntlet during Avengers 4 when he's
fighting the full team here like you
look at their big raid party so Captain
Marvel becomes their tank she can soak
some of his damage but number two the
other big reason why she's important
quantum energy enhanced Captain Marvel
buffed at the beginning of their fight
so remember she can soak energy meaning
she can soak quantum energy which is
sort of the new frontier in the Marvel
Universe
during him and the wasp they explained
quantum energy is sort of
catch-all for plot devices it allows you
to travel between dimensions in the
multiverse he can generate a lot more
power than something like Iron Man's arc
reactors he created new elements for
that during Iron Man 2 which explain why
they're so powerful
imagine quantum energy being way more
powerful than that and then also quantum
energy can function as a back door
time-travel device when nebula is saying
the Captain Marvel is her new BFF is not
because nebula likes making new friends
it's because she's the one person that's
critical to accomplishing nebulas
mission defeating Thanos at the end of
Avengers 4 in rescuing Gamora from the
soul stone and for those of you asking
yeah we're still close to getting that
Captain Marvel trailer but like I've
said before I'm not really expecting
that to happen till October maybe even
November but congratulations to M Holman
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big video please email me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details click here to rewatch
that Iron Man Illuminati scene and click
here to learn all about Hawkeye and
Avengers 4 thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]